My neck!
My [Screaming] HOAAAAAAAHHHH!!!!
My back! My pussy and my crack. *Crush* *man screaming in Pain*
♫ Habadum, habadum, humbum. ♫ *glass shattering*
Wuhuhuuuut the fuuuuk?
You mean this isn't how to do this right? *More Broken Glass sounds*
[high pitched]Ahh! I'm just a single mother looking for loooooo- [laughing] -ve...
The escape room, click on an object to- [:O]
Whaaaaat? *Beep x2*
Ooh, I need a screwdriver? *Wooden Drawer Opening*
Ooh, I picked up a secret code?
Okay
Ooh. Aah.
Screwdriver?
Yes?
Key?
*door unlocking* Yeah!?
Go to door! Okay.
*Very Raspy Gasp*
Don't move!
Yeah! Did I make it? Yeeeeeah!
I did- Wow.
Virtually impossible? But in what way?
Let me do a sick flip into death.
OHHHAUGH. *Many Stabbing noises*
Alright, let's try this sick flip again!
Woopie-eugh. *Stabbing noises* *crack* *man screeming in pain*
♫ I'm like an arrow! ♫
Weee!! *stabbing noises* *man whining in pain*
[laughing] So the trick is just don't fucking move!
Well, here we go. *Many Bottles Breaking*
[Shouted] Shabbada shabbada shabbada shabbada shaboooo! Shamoo! Shebbedeh!
Oooh, that was easy!
That was ea- Oh, hello.
Where are we going?
Why are we going backwards now?
Son? I think, you might need to prepare yourself for some immediate death happening.
Because I have a funny feel- [gasped] *Bottles Breaking* Oh god no!
So the trick is to balance on the front wheel, I think.
*Many Bottles Breaking* [Multiple screams] *Crush* AH! NO! YOU TRICKSTER! Oh, you bitch!
Okay. Wait (x5)...
[Gasped] [Laughing Proudly] Yeah!
Tetris is dangerous!
Oh no. What's gonna happen to me?
Am I going to... survive????
Oh, [gasped] hahahaha.
Let me just- I'm gonna lay down on this tetris block over here.
Nothing's gonna get me!
Am I safe up here? I have a funny feeling.
I'm gonna be okay!
So far so goo!
Wait, how- how high is this gonna build up?
My butt is vulnerable where I'm at right now!
Oh god, wait a minute...
Something doesn't seem fair about this.
[Screamed] Ah, no! Oh, god! *Crush*
[Markimoo sounds coming up again]
I wish I didn't stick my butt out so much.
Ah! *man Screaming in pain* Oh, [gasped] Oh, Oh Ho Ho Huh!
Well, I guess I don't need to worry about the “butt problems” anymore!
Woah! I forgot! That's a trickster!
Well! I have so much more maneuverability now.
AH!! OH GOD! *Crush*
Okay, we're good. Wait, we're not good.
Hup! Ho, ho, ho got outta that sitch!
Hep, backflip into SURVIVAL! *Crack* *Man Shouting In Pain*
[Screamed] Ah, no! Save me, [loud] save me!
Somebody? Ohh...
Uh oh, not my butt!
Owooohow just g- ahh fuck! AHH! OH! *Snap* *Man Screaming In Pain*
[Screaming]  OHH! AHHHH!
*Moist Burst* [Gasped] AH!! What the hell happened there? Why did I just explode?
Wacky, wavy inflatable arm flailing tube man! *Pogo Stick Breaks*
*Snap* Oh... What, hey! Wait a minute!
I can't grab? *Snap*
[Screamed] Oh god, no! Save me! Ah, *Crush* *man Screaming In Pain* oh, oh, oh...
Still... Alive! Somehow!
Boink!
Alright! [Loud] Oh!
Is that a way out?
eeuuuuhhhh!
Ah, oh god! Oh wait, hang on, I just gotta be-
OOO!! Get up against the-
*Crush* [Screamed loudly] No!
Butt, why did you betray me?
♫ Shoobi dee woob, woob, woob! ♫
Don't- No! [Screamed] No! *Snap* *Man Whining In Pain*  Ah...
Hep! Whoa! No! *Snap* [Screamed] Ah!
Where am I going? [Screamed] Oh ho god...
Well, at least, life is fine and dandy...
[Screamed insanely loud] OOHHHHH! *Crush*
I'm ready, primed and ready!
Whoa, not ready! God, damn it!
To the same- *Crush* God damn thing...
Ehh! Get back! (x3)
*Crush* [Long] Ah...
[Very long] Soo, I gootta wait for my opportuuuniitiayyy...
There it is! That's what I was waiting for!
That's what I was slappin' on!
[Screamed insanely loud] No! *Crush*
[Long and loud] Ahhhhh, fuck you!
Oh no! Okay, dodge this way!
Houp! Okay, dodge back!
Bring it back, make that ass clap!
[Loud] Ah, fuck off!
What are you doin'?  *Electronic Beeping* No! Oh god! No (x5), that sounds like mines and bombs!
Wait, houp! Okay, we're fine! We're fine...
We're fi- [Screamed loudly] No! God （。 ㅅ 。） fuck!
EEAAAH!!
Okay, I think, we're good!
I think, we're good!
Like, we knew that we [screamed] go fucking forward, you du-
AH NOO!!!!!!!
OH GOD SAAVE MEE!!!
AAAAH!!
*boom*
[Gasped] Ah, fucking "cock ass"!
This is an endevor
*squish*
AHAHAHA WHAT THE FUNOHOHOHO
Hep! *Snap* [Screamed] Ah! Oh, fucking cock ass!
There is- Whoa!
No! [Screamed] No! Come - on- *Crush* fuck you!
no
NO!
NO!!
NO!!!
NAO!!!
NO!!!!
ffuck OFF
GET OUT
NAO!!!
FUCK OFF
JUST FUCKING!!
[Screamed insanely loud] Are you fucking kidding me? *Crush*
No. Why?
Why?
no
no!
NO
NO NO
NO!!
WHAT THE FAAAA!!! *fades*
Okay! Whoop! Whoa. No! *Snap* God, no! Fucking *Crush* cock!
[Long] Why... are you doin' that?
[Screamed long] TO MEEEE! WHAT THE FUUUCK???
Hmpf! Fuck you! *Electronic Beeping*
Okay! Got it! Okay, just...
Ehh!
Just... fucking- Okay yes! (x2)
[Long] Hah!
[Screamed happily] Yes! (Background: Victory Sound)
[Long] Oh my god!
[Long inhaling] WHAAAAATT... THE FUUUUUUUCK!
Uh, kiddies, the level title is "Ninjas Only"...
Oh, if this has anything to do with farmers only, I'm gonna have a good time! AHUEHUE*Quiet Explosion*
A Huhuh! Oh, kids! Oh, kids! Kids! [Long screamed] Ah! *Stabbing Noises*
[Long] Ah, I don't think this is right! *Explosion*
Uhow, bam! (Background: Exploding landmine)
Ah, fuck! *Stabbing Noises*
Come along, kiddies! *Explosion* [Screamed long and loud] Woo! (x2)
[Long and loud] I'm cheating!
*Many Stabbing Noises* Fuck- Ah, fuck! Ah, god damn it!
[Screamed long and loud] I'm still cheating! *Stabbing Noises* Fuck all of you! To- ow...
*Spinning Blade Tearing Through Flesh* [Screamed loudly, gasped] AH!!! My own helicopter betrayed me!
Alright, pogo man! (Background: Exploding landmine) Ow!
Alright Pogo Man! *Stabbing Noises* Fuck!
Pogo Man *stabbing Noises* ooww!
Haha, you thought, you had me? But the answer was: You somehow got me!
Nyehh! [Screamed loudly] Whoa! *Stab* *Man Whining In Pain*
[Screamed long and loudly] Ah, shi- Oh, fuck off, man!
Ow! Just need to *Stab* spear my butthole on that for- *Explosion* [Long] Oh!
Euhh, that was a close one! *Stab* Ah- Oh, come on!
Bah! Nuu, mmm, fuuck! no, no,
Yes! (x4)
[Victoriously screamed] YES! Okay, got it, got it, got it... *Stab*
Kiiiid, it is goin' badly for us! Ohhhh, *Smash* aw shit! [blood spills]
Kid, you alright back there? Huh, you doin' fine?
[Screamed long] Woobiedie woo!
Ah, *Snap* fuck you!
W W- Wahh, fuck! Hang on! Wait!
Aw, god damn it!
Ahh, get ready for the "Double-under-turnover" *Crush* ... Shit!
Get ready for the "Ass-blaster 9-"... *Snap* bluh!
Get ready for the... uhh the... "Fondleballer"... *Snap*
Get ready for the "Asshole Inspection"! [Laughed] Can you just take a good look up my butthole?
Get ready for the- [Sigh] Ah... Get ready for the pacifist!
Get ready for the "Paci-FIST"! *Smash*
[Gasped] [Laughing] Oh, Gee-!
Get ready for "Unpleasent 69"!
[Laughing] Well, this certainly is unpleasent..
[Slurred] Get ready for the "Awkward divorce"! *Smash* Oh, shit!
Get ready for "Jeff Goldbloom's Kiss"! *Smash* [Shock] Oh!
Get ready for the "Tender loving embrace"! *Crush* [Giggling] Oh, Geez! Too much love!
(Background: "Crazy la Paint" fading in) [Gasped] ERRH! Oh-ho-ho, god! Erh! Well, kiddies! What. Do. You. Want. For, [screamed loudly] CHRISTMAS?!?!?!?
(Background: "Crazy la Paint") This has been: "Happy Wheels Highlights"!
Thanks, for watching, and if you want to see more Happy Wheels right now, check the description or click the annotation for the full Happy Wheels Playlist!
And, if you want to see more Happy Wheels in the future, please click the Like Button to let me know!
Thanks again everyone, and as always, I will see you, in the next video. Buh bye!
(Background: "Crazy la Paint" fading out)